well president Trump is walking back
comments he made about a possible
treatment for the corona virus on
Thursday after suggesting people ingest
disinfectant to kill the virus resident
now says he was being quote sarcastic on
Friday public officials and the makers
of some household cleaners warned the
public not to consume disinfectant and
that led to a surprising move yesterday
at the White House Nikole Killion is
there this morning Nicole good morning
good morning Michele in a rare move
president Trump did not take any
questions during last night's briefing
the White House press secretary says he
had already taken countless questions
and has been transparent president drums
Friday night coronavirus task force
briefing lasted less than half an hour
without some of his top health experts
present but earlier in the day I was a
sarcastic and a very sarcastic question
to the reporters in the room about
disinfectant on the inside the president
insisted he was kidding when he said
this during Thursday's briefing is there
way we can do something like that by
injection inside went viral but on Fox
News she explained the president was
only talking it through I think he just
saw the information at the time
immediately before the press conference
and he was still digesting that
information the Food and Drug
Administration issued its own warning
Friday about hydroxychloroquine a
malaria drug often promoted by the
president cautioning it could cause
irregular heart rhythms the results have
been very good so you hear both ways
I've seen all know the president also
signed a four hundred and eighty four
billion dollar measure replenishing the
paycheck protection program for small
businesses and including eight two
hospitals
but he threatened to block a loan for
the US Postal Service unless it hiked
shipping rates the Postal Service is it
joke that emergency loan is for ten
billion dollars we reached out to the
Postal Service for comment but earlier
this month it warned the pandemic has
been devastating for business the
president thinks the agency is
mismanaged but tweeted he would never
let the post office fail Dana
alright Nicole thank you